mes chers amis je suis très heureux
d'être aujourd'hui parmi vous je salue
tous ceux qui sont présents à notre
réunion militants cadres ministre cheikh
jacqueline shermarke cher geneviève
schehr sarah cher nathalie élu
parlementaire patrick responsable du
parti cher jean noël et cher françois
nous sommes tous engagés et rassemblés
dans un moment particulier difficile et
exigeant de la vie de notre pays de
l'europe et du monde
mais permettez moi d'abord un message
plus personnel je veux dire à chacune et
chacun d'entre vous un très grand merci
pour les nombreux messages de soutien et
d'encouragement que vous m'avez envoyé
cela m'a beaucoup touché et je veux vous
dire une chose j'ai vraiment hâte de
vous retrouver tous chers amis vous le
comprendrez je veux savoir
et plus précisément aujourd'hui une
pensée pour valéry giscard d'estaing la
campagne de 74 est un moment
formidablement joyeux et très heureux
nous en parlions encore au téléphone
avec jacqueline giscard à changer en
profondeur et durablement la société
française il l'a fait contre tous les
conservatismes de l'époque et ils
étaient nombreux
près d'un demi siècle plus tard ses
grandes réformes je pense en particulier
à celles qui ont changé la vie des
femmes continuent d'entrer en résonance
avec chacune et chacun de nous c'est
dire leur force dans le temps et leur
caractère universel et puis giscard
avait une obsession apaisé moderniser la
vie politique française permettre que
deux français sur trois c'était son
expression puissent se retrouver sur des
objectifs majeurs pour le pays
cette intuition de giscard elle était
valable en 1974 elle l'est plus encore
aujourd'hui en temps de crise nous ne
réglerons aucun des grands problèmes
notre pays tant que nous resterons
diviser et opposer notre démocratie
française doit vraiment évolué elle doit
devenir adulte et majeur avec un
parlement qui exercent pleinement ses
missions
un exécutif qui souhaitent aller coûte
du parlement bien sûr mais aussi de la
société civile dans son ensemble
on ne peut pas gouverner changer ce qui
doit l'être faire les grands choix
nécessaires pour préparer l'avenir si on
n'en mène pas à bord une très large
majorité de français
or je crois que c'est possible le jour
viendra
c'est ma conviction profonde où nous
devrons créer des convergences entre les
grandes sensibilités démocratique du
pays
sur quelques objectifs communs il faudra
le faire sérieusement en prenant le
temps et en approfondissant les sujets
et on verra alors que sur l'essentiel
les grands courants politiques de
gouvernements peuvent s'entendre pour le
bien du pays sans rien renier de ce
qu'ils sont de leur histoire et de leur
identité ce chemin là est possible et si
la france est capable de l'emprunter
elle en sortira plus forte et plus
respecté mes chers amis les crises
auxquelles nous devons faire face sont
immenses et nombreuses elle touche à
notre équilibre
elle touche à nos raisons de vivre si
nous savons tenir résisté le temps qu'il
faudra nous entraider donner le meilleur
de nous mêmes alors nous nous
retrouverons avec une énergie décuplée
et la folle envie d'aller de l'avant et
tous les espoirs seront possibles je
vous embrasse tous et je pense bien à
vous